remember when George Clooney was Batman
well if you forgot don't worry George is
not and he has no problem poking a
little fun in himself George went there
when asked who should be the next in
line to dawn to take Crusaders costume
country's I'm Batman I'm not sure I
screwed it up so badly I'm not allowed
to weigh in on any of those subject
matters anymore help me save another
life you actually thought I was the best
Batman you said I did say yeah it's top
in a new interview for variety
George sits down with Christopher Abbott
who co-stars with Clooney in catch-22 as
some catch that catch-22 George also
directs the Hulu limited series it's his
return to the small screen which
launched him into superstardom I've been
binge-watching er haven't watched it yet
et was with George from the beginning of
ER where he gave us a tour of the set as
part of the whole catheter no jr. don't
squeeze the catheter bag thing but
Christopher never watched George's dr.
Doug Ross I haven't no no it wasn't
required oh it was that on the sill oh
never mind that was on the stove it I
feel edited you know he thinks gonna
happen
the two are on the cover of the new
issue of variety Christopher used to
play Allison Williams boyfriend on girls
who knew George was a fan sort of that's
how we got the part because I'm uh i
watch girls religiously I actually went
back and watched a couple of episodes of
Chris on girls and I listen it's not
fully my cup of tea is a show but that's
you know probably because I'm a 57 year
old man you know these are wonderful
actors so he did a great job I can't I
can't be rotten right now I want to be
but I don't have nothing rotten to say
right now I will all find some insanity
is contagious
okay so George has nothing bad to say
about his co-star but guess why his
twins will turn 2 on June 6th and there
is nothing like those terrible twos
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]